uh
i had no idea that they had their own
language aren't
like all the royalty princes and princes
of wales
towing honestly to me looks like a
little baby just got mad at the keyboard
it went like this
tywin that's how you spell taiwan
lannister isn't it taiwan
no it's not taiwan to win
[Music]
oh my god why do the two wives make
different noises
this looks like a game of hangman that i
lost right like there are a bunch of
dashes and i just didn't get the vowels
do you cry much that looks like an
advertisement for an antidepressant
serum the accent is key
creamy creamy so the why is an uh
i think i could mess with this language
anissa
what what is that
that looks like a rapper's name like
young subal
uh usable me initiable nice boy
okay sounds like what you say when
you're cold you're just like
and it's asparty is tooth the top looks
like a
like a dumb startup that you'd see in
silicon valley isabidi begin
uh will bitey wasaiti is pity
is twitter
i'm sorry what that's so cool
this is the coolest language
[Music]
santa yeah no i'm just gonna go
i'm just come down
that's a that's this is one word were
they drunk when they named this town
this is a town
lawn fair playground
goger sherwin
nailed it
[Music]
what no that's like that sounds like
you're making this out it sounds like an
ancient prayer
more than a town i think welsh people
value
city names i think in america it's kind
of an afterthought i still want to go to
wales
because it's beautiful i hear
i don't want to ever have to follow
directions there
it's very interesting that it's so close
to england
and we associate it with being like
england
but it's it's so very different